[Autumn Economic Forecast 2020]
The coronavirus pandemic, which has claimed
so many lives around the world,
[Paolo Gentiloni, Commissioner for Economy]
The coronavirus pandemic, which has claimed
so many lives around the world,
has caused unprecedented economic damage too.
Rapid and colossal support
from governments and the EU has helped
to cushion some of the impact
and growth has been recovering.
But uncertainty is still high.
Overall, the European economy,
like the global economy,
is forecast to contract
significantly this year
before bouncing back over
the course of 2021 and 2022.
The recovery, like the recession was,
is expected to be uneven,
with some countries and sectors
set to benefit more than others.
Financial support from the governments
and the EU has been vital for businesses
and citizens this year
and will play a defining role in the recovery.
Public deficits are therefore expected
to be significantly higher than in recent years
for as long as such exceptional support is needed.
The same is true for public debt,
which is forecast to rise markedly this year.
Government programmes and EU initiatives
such as SURE have helped to limit job losses in Europe,
but some increase in unemployment will be inevitable.
Inflation, by contrast, should fall this year
due to the economic contraction
and the drop in oil prices.
We are living in exceptional times.
Europe’s economic outlook depends
heavily on the evolution of the pandemic
and other factors such as developments
in international trade and the global economy.
The crisis has shown that
Europe is capable of powerful policy responses
that can make a huge,
meaningful difference to our citizens’ lives.
The €750 billion Next Generation EU programme
will have a sizeable
positive impact in all our Member States
and will help prepare Europe
for a more prosperous, fairer, green and digital future.